what I want to say to people is you know
your body other people are not living in
your body you know your body and you
need to believe yourself I'm Lori
Gottlieb I'm a therapist and author and
this is the air between us all
[Music]
so let's face it it's difficult and
awkward to open up about personal health
issues which is why Amgen is on a
mission to give people living with
asthma and their loved ones an
opportunity to create stronger
connections with each other to have more
empathetic conversations and to develop
a deeper consideration for the
challenges of managing asthma I'm Hannah
I have severe asthma hi my name is ill
this is my husband Trigg and I have
asthma hi I'm kit and I have asthma
having an asthma attack feels I feel
constricted I can't breathe I panic I
feel like my ribs are trying to press it
down but my lungs can't expand outwards
you literally feel like you can't
breathe you wheeze I feel exhausted
it like for you when you were growing up
and you didn't really know what was
going on did people understand what was
happening for you well I think my mom
thought that I was making things up for
a long time because she's like the
doctor says there's nothing wrong with
you I was born with asthma though the
doctor didn't realize I had asthma until
about a year old my mom was trying to
convince them because it runs in my
family I know my immediate family
understood I feel like I don't I never
feel like tell anyone I have asthma I
just kind of deal with it on my own
sometimes it's really difficult to
explain my severe asthma to my friends
and family and I just don't know how to
how to get across them that is in fact
severe asthma as an adult it's harder
for me to share than as a kid which is
really interesting what is it that makes
you hesitate people start you
differently they have
their perception of you shifts a little
bit because I work as a dancer and last
year I was on a tour and a lot of the
cast members liked to go out after the
show and I specifically don't want to
like be in a place with this smoke
because I don't want to put my lungs
into that area so I'll just stay on the
bus what I think you don't realize is
people probably miss you and so if you
were to tell them the truth I think
people would be so willing to include
you in the activities in a way that
works for you so what are some of the
tips you have for more effectively
communicating my needs I think the thing
to remember is that everybody's dealing
with something so I think being open
with them also brings you closer because
then you're being open you're being
vulnerable and you're usually not asking
for much and I can't imagine anyone
being like no no that's the thing well
that that's that's such a great point
because people don't say no yeah I mean
usually people say oh I had no idea yes
tell me how I can help what are some of
the best ways to discuss health
challenges with a romantic partner my
husband that's such a great question
because it's not just one conversation
it's a series of conversations and it's
part of your life and it will come up
organically and I think the way to talk
about it is not to kind of dump all the
information at once just laying it out
very simply this is what asthma is I
live with asthma here are some triggers
for me and that's just a great place to
start yes so when we met I did let him
know like I have asthma he was used to
seeing me stay prepared you know making
sure I had everything in my purse just
in case I had an attack I love that you
brought it up early on so that the
conversation was broached it's open and
now there's a place to go with it
because Zeal was vulnerable with you
early on and she opened up to you about
living with asthma did that make you
feel more comfortable being vulnerable
with her at the beginning of the
relationship it was actually a relief
that she was that transparent because
then I can I can be yourself be myself
be more vulnerable and share my life
experiences when I've been through as
well so it builds Trust I think it's so
important for people living with a
chronic condition not to make their
lives small and I think once they open
up about it and they talk to the people
around them about it they can feel safe
I feel like my biggest takeaways from
the conversation that we had is to be
strong which means to be vulnerable
people will be encouraging people will
be accommodating and I I need to go out
and tell people what I hope people will
do is if they start talking about this
that they can work with the people
around them to find a way to do the
activities that they like to do so
you're not making your life smaller but
you can still have this big beautiful
life thank you all for joining us and
remember vulnerability empathy and open
communication are the greatest tools to
bring us closer together and to clear
the air between us all
thank you